accessing these ravished Bahamian
islands is a massive challenge as more
rescue and recovery teams begin to make
their way in the more stark this
devastating ordeal becomes the number of
people killed by the category 5
hurricane is growing the US Coast Guard
is at the very beginning of its rescue
mission because of debris in the water
the only safe way out is by helicopter
the extent of what they're dealing with
is plain to see but they are reaching
the most vulnerable survivors who
endured a sustained hours-long attack at
the hands of Hurricane Dorian getting
them to safety with such limited means
is a delicate and slow process the
British Navy is also doing what it can
to assist the relief effort these are
the conditions that led to the
destruction a holiday paradise
obliterated by powerful wind gusts of
over 200 miles per hour and torrential
rainfall Kimberly is four months
pregnant she was finally evacuated after
hours of hell
nobody thought okay we never used to be
scared of whether we're like oh okay
which is a different story other evacuee
what's next
there's only relief that finally being
safe 30 years and you watched it
disappear yeah when I look up again I
look right up in the sky you're here and
you're smiling and you'll say well
you're gonna get word that people still
on the islands need these supplies fast
because of the state of marinas and
airports in the worst-affected areas
helicopters are crucial in getting those
supplies in and they're also absolutely
vital when it comes to bringing people
in those most vulnerable sick evacuees
who may be injured elderly immediately
get into these ambulances and has taken
to hospital in Nassau the road to
recovery is desperately long Amanda
Walker Sky News Nassau the Bahamas